i came up doing comedy in new york the
old-school way
in dark little smokey rooms
these crowds just came to laugh because
they needed to laugh
when we were doing this special we
wanted to capture what that was like and
that's what this is ladies and gentlemen
mr d.c benny
[Applause]
long island's good to be here long
island yeah
across the street from the gas station
good to be here
next to the kosher deli that closed down
for the health violation that's always
good
you know throwing bacon bits into matzo
balls that'll do it
the word gets out uh people always look
at me they're like yeah you don't look
like uh you're gonna be funny
uh you look like one of those dudes
that'll you'll rent the boat from you
get out on the water there's a hole in
the bottom
i hear that a lot people say i look like
jeff goldblum if he did some time
i hear that some lady in i lived in a
building for two years this lady thought
i was the super of the building
uh the superintendent you know for two
years she would come up to me with very
specific maintenance requests
it should be like hector hector
my sink is clogged again and i have to
tell her mirror coming in 10 minutes
they may not coming i better piss you
all the time people calling seven
minutes 10 minutes coming
i didn't know if that joke would work in
long island because you guys have lawns
and houses you guys don't have supers
with the key rings and everything
it's good for me to get out of you know
work in a city a lot of people another
thing here's another thing i have people
ask me for directions they asked me for
directions all the time like uh
you know i was standing uh i was staying
i was in i was in city some lady came up
and uh
just goes and it's it's new york so they
don't ask they just demand
you know this lady comes up and just
goes broadway not where is it or how do
i get to it
or any of that other stuff you'd
associate with a question it's confusing
i'm like is she requesting a show tune
is that a is that a code like my flies
down oh broadway thank you lady
so i had to ask i was like can you
clarify what it is exactly you need so
then she treats me like an idiot she
puts it in a
in a question form but says it really
slowly she's like how
do i get to
broadway so i gave her the most new york
answer i could think of i was like well
that all depends on how big you can
dream
all right yeah that happened everybody
so uh live in brooklyn live in brooklyn
you guys know it over there that's the
money yeah sure
it's fancy now you know my
neighborhood's changing a lot
changing a lot i've been there like 30
years my neighbor has been you know like
okay so i go to this deli pretty much
every day in my neighborhood i go to
this deli
so uh i go the other day to get uh cat
food a coating of cat food that's one of
my
rituals and um i'm in line
and there's one of the newer people in
the neighborhood on the phone behind me
very loud like seriously
literally really seriously literally
really i can't even
you know just sentence fragments
and then uh and then they start
critiquing the neighborhood they're like
if i'm going to be totally transparent
about this neighborhood i have to say my
major problem with it is that it lacks
diversity
i'm like wait a minute now it's mostly
old school italian neighborhood but
we're you know in a korean deli there's
a mexican dude behind the counter making
a bagel for the jewish lady
who is of course complaining because she
ordered in everything with nothing it's
blowing his mind he's trying to give her
a plane
he's trying to give her a plane there's
a crackhead trying to buy a lucy what's
missing like a one-legged outfit
in in capri pants like what's missing
you know
so now i'm up at bat i get to the to the
register right
to buy my cat food i realize i forgot my
wallet
but i know the guy i've been coming here
30 years so i told the guy i'm like
listen
uh i'm going to hit you off later today
when i come through again and before
he could respond the person behind me on
the phone in reference to me
says really loudly white privilege i was
like
so i went outside i stole their bike and
i left a note that said reparations
my neighbor still has some kind of old
school stuff just still that old school
crime
that happens in my neighborhood haven't
totally gentrified it
you know like uh uh my car has been
broken into
uh eight times in the last two months so
i've been obsessed i'm glad you're
laughing
and they whoever it is takes random
stuff like 43 cents and the owner's
manual you know
it feels very personal i feel very
violated
so i'm like i'm gonna oh i'm just go i
can't i'm gonna i'm obsessed with just
catching whoever it is i'm having
violent fantasies if i could only catch
this person if i could only catch
about a week ago uh i'm laid up in my
underwear it's midnight watch the tv
only tell you the underwear part because
it figures into the story and i hear the
alarm go off and i look out the window
and there's a little dude
in my car going through my stuff and uh
uh he's got an ikea bag because it's
brooklyn you know
and that's not the blue one you're
allowed to have it's the yellow one
that's not supposed to leave the store
so i'm like that's a [ __ ] career
criminal
over there look at that you know some
banging on the window and he's like [ __ ]
you buddy i'm like oh it's on now it's
on you know so i run out of house i'm
chasing this guy i'm booking after this
guy realized two blocks into it
i was so i was so angry about the whole
thing i didn't i didn't put on pants i'm
chasing this guy in my underwear
i got on flip-flops and i have that
plantar fasciitis where you gotta have
the uh
the insoles uh you know every stepper
it's like ah
i don't have my glasses i'm falling
apart i'm the tin man chasing this guy
you know
so this is not thought out you know
so i actually i finally catch up to him
and now is my moment right i
catch up to him and uh he's like i'm
sorry you know and it's
and he's got and and you know and now's
my moment to reap the violence that i've
been thinking about but
but then i'm thinking about i'm like
wait a minute it's it's midnight i can't
see really what's going on he's four
he's got his arm behind the bag like he
might have something like i know a box
cutter or something like that
and you know i'm in my underwear you
know it's just so uh but i'm like i want
it to stop i have to do something
so i improvise uh i just say to him i
said listen man
if you ever come to this neighborhood
again uh i'm gonna have to rape you
right and i don't know where that came
from
i don't know where that came from right
i mean if you know me that's
i mean as i'm saying like
because new york is freaky he could have
just been like you know bent over and
been like certainly now i gotta butt
[ __ ] this guy by the bqe
to prove a point for justice
but anyway
that guy laughed uh these jokes were one
person at a time
uh but anyway you know it had the
desired effect he was horrified he took
off right so
now so i go back to my place yeah i put
on pants shoes shirt
i go to the precinct there's two blocks
away uh and i'm like listen there was a
guy
breaking into cars um
we uh i pursued him we had a discussion
uh and they're like let's let's let's go
for a ride let's go fight let's go for a
ride let's go find this [ __ ] [ __ ]
suck over there
and they put out there i mean they're
very amped up right and they put out the
apb
uh there's some guy over there with the
uh you know with the [ __ ] ikea bag
running around and breaking their cars
just go [ __ ] find it
you know so i'm driving around within 10
minutes they get a call
uh that that they you know they've
hemmed up this guy over there on sackett
street red hook or whatever
you know meets the description we drive
over there i see the guy like the lights
on him
you know and he's pacing back and forth
and everything
and and the cop with me he's like that's
the guy right that's the guy
and i'm like wait wait a minute wait
because he had a hat on and he didn't
have a hat before and you know you want
to be
100 sure you know you've seen those hbo
documentaries it's the wrong person
and then you go to jail and lives are
ruined and everything so i'm like you
know he didn't have a hat on so the guy
the cop next to they take off the hat
right dude takes off the hat he's like
that's
him right that's that [ __ ] duck
sucker i'm like
easy it happened to me we weren't there
you know
let me see so i'm like i still he's a
little far off i can't see the
his facial features i'm not 100 i got to
be 100 sure so i'm like listen man
maybe you could come a little closer so
cop's like listen i'm gonna go out i'm
gonna ask you some questions you
eyeballs
[Laughter]
whatever like all right all right so
have i asked him some questions i see
the guy's face i see him up close i hear
his voice you know he's like i
didn't do anything i'm like that's the
guy hundred percent hundred percent
cop gets back in the car he's like dad
jim right that's him i'm like yeah
actually that that is him he's like i
knew it i'm like how'd you know it he's
like he's all sweaty
i'm like why you all sweat he's like i
was out running why are you running at
midnight
some dude was chasing me threatening to
rape me so
[Laughter]
a little wholesome rape story for
everybody
my comedy is not for everybody i found
that out you know there are people who
do not think i'm funny
uh where was i was working in
chattanooga tennessee
uh which is the indian name for there's
nothing to do in this town
oh the crowds hated me the first night i
was there i made a joke about uh dale
earnhardt
someone in the audience stood up and
went easy easy
it was all quiet except for the sound of
pitchforks or sharpening you know
but the thing is you got to embrace
wherever you go you got to embrace
the differences you know that's that's
how i feel about it so
i'm like what do they have a chat that
we don't have they had the bass pro shop
that never been to the bass pro shop
somebody over there yeah it's a big
hunting fishing store
and you walk in it's like baron you know
people are buying guns like it's produce
give me two of those give me that big
one from mama
look at that i'll kill your ball bearing
there and aaron
and deer hunting season it just started
so they had these things that look like
crack files so ask the guy what's that
he goes that's butt lure
i'm like what is he going that's deer
urine i'm like well what do you do with
he goes you take it
you sprinkle it on yourself the deer
smell you he think you a deer
and that's when you get i'm them
that's bizarre i didn't know all that
went into hunting like you have a golden
shower before you run into the woods
it's a little
little kicking right it's a little
kicking
how do you collect deer is there is
there a dude in the woods with a bucket
you know that one looked kind of full
you know i don't know if deer are like
eyes and you know
peeing in public and i can't if you're
looking you know
but the best thing about the bass pro
shop is they have a giant tv monitor
and it's like uh two guys and they make
the it's like a hunting tv show
right and they have two guys they make
this uh they run it in a constant loop
this show did you guys make a little
tree house up there
they got a bow and arrow and they're
gonna they're gonna whack some deer but
there's a lot of down time
before the deer shows up started
whispering to each other
about how they're going to kill this
deer if you don't see the visual you're
just here to audio
it sounds like gay southern porn yeah
it's like oh look down there look at the
head on that that's a big old head
that's like a 12 pointer look at that
dart be still now be still
i'm just gonna pull back nice and slow
right just
relax don't jerk it don't jerk it
look at him bent over by that brook i'ma
mount him in my living room
there and in there
one thing i'm really good at is making
bad decisions
um i'm going to give you an example
everybody you know
everybody uh uh it's it's gotten very
sensitive it was very sensitive now
the comedic climate everything's very
sensitive you know people send emails
they're
you know you know
everybody gets offended an email gets
sent you know your career is leaking in
the gutter
you know so years ago it used to not be
like that
you know i mean i i i look my sense of
humor i i do alienate
uh you know i've lost a few friends
but you know you know like i one friend
recently is not my friend anymore but
you know he came over he was hungry
so i make him a sandwich i bring it out
he's like i can't eat that i said well
why not he goes because i have a gluten
allergy
i'm like well what are the symptoms of
that exactly he says well
first you feel full and then you feel
tired i'm like well that's exactly
what's supposed to happen when you eat
bread
you're not supposed to be famished and
then alert
anyway but here's my point so years ago
i don't feel like it used to be like
that like when i was doing comedy in the
city years ago i mean i would
you could say whatever you wanted you
know when somebody gets offended they
leave
you know but i remember there was a
period of time i got sick of doing my
act
i i i wanted to do something on purpose
that was offensive as
as it could be and just see what
happened so i i was started doing this
character
on stage and people believed it was real
they it was this angry middle eastern
comic
uh called the great habibi right
and i came out you know my opening joke
was i hate jews
uh orange juice apple juice
and people love the great habibi right
people love the great habibi right
i did an album as the great habibi i
sold one copy
one copy to a to a guy who lived in the
middle east ironically enough some guy
in the middle east bought the one copy
right so the way i would i would do the
you know i committed like i grew a beard
you know i mean i do the whole
you know i took less frequent showers i
put on extra cologne i mean i did the
whole thing
i called strangers my friend um
and the album cover was hilarious it was
a picture of me like on a flying carpet
it was so offensive
you know smoking a hookah with a camel
you know
throwing rocks at americans you know
anyway
and the way i would i would try the
material there was the again there was a
deli in my neighborhood and it was two
guys from yemen muhammad and muhammad
and uh i love these guys and i would run
the material by them i'd be like you
know i hate jews they'd be like
hilarious this is hilarious already
what the coincidence so do we
and one of the muhammads uh one of the
muhammads i forget which one
uh he was a big mr t fan he loved mr t
had mr t bobblehead uh mr t posters
from the a team like he had this whole
mr t obsession i remember
asking him one day i was like what what
is the obsession with mr t
and we he goes to me he goes mr t he is
big and black i'm small and brown
inside i'm him inside he is me we had
this like
very it was a beautiful little moment
you know resonated maybe he had to be
there i got a tear everything
so during this time during this time
there was another middle eastern comic
working in new york
city his closing joke was he would rip
open his shirt
and he had fake dynamite strapped to his
chest and people be like ha ha
and then leave you know it was a
different time
it was a different time so 911 happened
so he
stops working you know i think he went
into banking or something
and you know i i dialed back to greater
bibi a little bit but i'm still doing it
so a few months later
i get a call from some producer in los
angeles and he's like listen we hear you
do this great habibi thing
ah we wanna uh we're casting a show it's
a cop show
with a middle eastern guy and we think
you'd be perfect we want you to fly
yourself out and that's always a good
sign when somebody says that
no fly yourself out to los angeles for
this meeting and everything it's gonna
be everybody's gonna be here it's gonna
be perfect we're gonna cast you in this
thing so i'm like
okay so i have like two days to get this
all together money's a little tight so i
have a friend named tony woods
hilarious comedian and tony has a hookup
at an airline
right so i'm like tony you got that hook
up at the airline he's like yeah
shorty and i'm like uh what's the guy's
name he's like his name is horse
i'm like horse why is he called horse
he's like man you don't want to know
so i meet this guy horse in the back of
a bar
he comes limping in you know
[Laughter]
i'm trying not to look at his leg you
know
you know and uh and horse uh he's like
i give him 200 cash he's like here take
this number
use it on the way over take this other
number use it on the way back
so i'm like okay right but it's it seems
a little it seems a little dodgy right
like all right you know next day i fly
out
use the number it's fine the producer
picks me up at the airport he's like
listen we're going directly to the
meeting
he goes uh i want you these people
believe that you're actually the great
habibi so i need you to be that guy in
the meeting so be offensive and
everything i'm like okay no problem
right so
we get to this building right it's this
agency whatever all the agents are
sitting at this table everybody sitting
around
you know a big big deal and everything
i'm sitting there and this one lady is
the shot caller she's the shot caller
right she starts grilling me asking me
questions she's like so uh
habibi um what country are you from
exactly i'm like uh you know where is
egypt
she's like yes i'm like not there it's
to the left it's called
it's a small uh it's a small place one
tenth
you know open sesame and then you go in
so everybody's laughing at the table
except for this lady so she keeps asking
me more questions
you know she's like so are you married
i'm like yes i have seven wives one for
each day of the week
you know tuesday is my favorite you know
i drill her like oilfield you know
fracking all night fracking in the butt
everybody's laughing at the table this
lady not laughing
she goes do you have children yes i have
my daughter she was born in the desert
sandy uh my other daughter she's a
little overweight fatima
uh and my son i call him my little
chickpea but when he misbehaved i beat
him with his stick and then i call him
thomas you know
everybody's laughing at this table this
lady not laughing
so she's like uh she's like do you have
any friends from the old country i'm
like yes i have one friend but they
caught him shoplifting and they chop his
hand
she goes so well what happened i'm like
he lost dutch right
i'm killing at this table this lady's
not laughing right
so she's like let me switch gears a
minute now one of the concerns here is
language
uh one of the concerns is language
you're if there's gonna be a language
barrier are there phrases that are
different like in
your language and culturally with
ireland and i was like yes like the
phrase
camelto you know
in my country is not insult is
compliment it means your vagina have the
strength of one thousand camels
she's like aha so what would an insult
be pita bread [ __ ] this mean
your vagina is dry like the desert but
there is a secret pocket with lots of
ingredients that you only discover when
you give a big taste to it
like an oasis pizza bread [ __ ]
i'm killing at this table no one's
laughing this lady's not laughing right
right then a guy comes over he's like
would you like coffee would you like
water would you like juice i'm like i
told you i hate juice
right so while this is going on i see in
the back of the agency all these younger
agents
they're going to this back room in a
mass and i'm like well what is going on
there and
and people tell me it's tea time i'm
like what does mean tea time
and they're like we represent mr t uh
he comes here once a month his career's
been a little rocky so he comes here
it's kind of like a pep talk
thing we have all these new agents we
have these posters here
of things he's done and he signs the
posters for the new agents and it makes
him feel better and so
they're like as a matter of fact since
you're here would you mind
uh getting a poster sign because you're
a new face i'm like no problem so i
stand in line it's surreal mr t doesn't
look good like there's a piece of the
mohawk missing
you know he looks like lowercase t or
something and uh
it's so surreal i mean he's sitting
there and he's he's signing these
posters and he's giving people 80s
advice you know he's like stay in school
don't be a fool right they're like
thanks t thanks thanks a lot t
he's like when you get rich buy your
mama a house thanks t
he gets to me he takes one look at me
he's like what are you some kind of
terrorist
and i was like no we like to say
conscientious detonator he's like hahaha
you crazy
you're crazy he's like what's your name
i was like put it to muhammad so he
writes muhammad
don't blow [ __ ] up you can't make this
up right i'm like this is the best thing
ever you know
so i gotta post it it says muhammad
don't blow [ __ ] i'm like wait till
muhammad see this or muhammad either one
so the next day the next day uh i go to
the airport i got my number i got my
number i
check in delta airlines or whatever the
lady's like four three seven eight two
one she's like huh
that's strange i don't seem to have a
reservation for that number like one
second let me just uh contact my travel
agent
i'm like horse he's like try seven eight
five
three seven like seven eight five three
seven six seven eight she's like
there's a number no seven eight five
three seven uh and he's like two
three eight five six so i'm like two
three eight five six ladies like two
three and she's like oh wait a minute
sir wait a minute
we can't take any more credit cards from
me or nobody this this has
been purchased on a stolen credit card
you know we who's that on the phone i'm
like horse click
uh so she's like you're gonna have to
pay cash for this ticket so
great so i got to go get cash i pay for
the ticket it's it's it's a nightmare
so i'm waiting for the waiting for the
plane to to board
right and my name is dc benny right that
is the stage name my real name
is ben wirtofsky nobody knows that [ __ ]
there's an announcement from delta
airlines as their
pre-board they're like well benwartovsky
please report to the front desk of delta
airlines i'm like ah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm not gonna do that
right but like ben wartoski please
report to this like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i get on the plane lands in jfk they're
about to
everybody's about to get off six guys in
suits get on there like everybody please
sit down we're looking for a ben
wartoski please identify yourself i'm
like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] right they're like then we're
talking we know you're on this plane
we have a flight manifest with your name
on it uh
we have a general description we're
going to go row by row until we find you
it's going to go better for you
if you identify yourself right now
people are looking around so i'm like oh
ben wittowski uh i had a headphone in my
ear
so uh they take me to this back room and
they start interrogating me they're like
where did you get this ticket
i'm like ah from a man named horse
they're like a man
named horse what are you a comedian i'm
like actually
um so while this is going on they're
going through my stuff so the guy's got
my passport he's like so you've been
watovsky
you're dc benny the other guy unrolls
the poster he's like are you muhammad
and what are you gonna blow up right so
i'm like now ow
now so i get on a do not fly list
for a year because of this [ __ ] right i
get on a dune i got to do local gigs
every i'm like i'm never gonna
i'm never gonna do the great habibi
again well a year ago
a little bit more i get a tour in israel
right
and i'm like ah this will be awesome
i've never been it'll be it's eight days
you know what i don't speak hebrew but i
make it up i take english and
you know same thing
[Laughter]
so i'm there and the shows are great
it's like every night we're in a
different place you know you know every
every night you know you eat a little
title yeah it'll be the title crushing
it yeah
the last night we're in tel aviv we're
in tel aviv we're performing there it's
been advertised everywhere it's a big
deal there's posters
american comedians and
that day trump announces that he is
moving the embassy
from tel aviv to jerusalem which is a
big [ __ ] deal i had no idea you know
it was a big deal so the whole place
it's like it's like
all american personnel get the [ __ ] out
of israel right take it
[Laughter]
you know so and so the mood is very
tense the mood is very tense but the
shows are
the show's great that night the next day
fly out but there's a four-hour layover
in istanbul
right and i don't know if you guys have
been in that airport but that airport is
like
it's like something from an indiana
jones movie i mean it's the dude with
the little
hat with the fizz thing and the you know
he's got the monkey
you know there's like one tooth and the
whole airport being passed around to
chew stuff you know
and they're they're burning trump and
effigy like there's a whole
like it's just like a not a good time to
be there right so i'm trying to keep a
very low profile
but these four guys keep following me
around right and everybody got like half
a soccer outfit and you know
they keep following me around so i'm
trying to lose these guys so i end up
hiding in the bathroom
getting up on top of the toilet in the
stall you know like you did in fourth
grade when you're gonna get your ass
beat
uh and i'm hiding in there and i'm like
all right i lost them
i get out of stall i go to leave they're
blocking the door i'm like no
and one of the guys comes up to me he's
like you got a mannequin yes
you at american i was like no
i am a great baby right
that guy looked at me he's like i know i
buy your album 15 years ago
so i signed a schwarmer rapper it was
awesome it was awesome
so uh married married uh and
we don't have kids you know for 24 years
we tried to want them
but just never you know
that's one of my favorite jokes i don't
know why
yeah my wife is black i'm not uh
so we have uh you know there's stuff
that happens like she has a natural skin
care company a big
natural skincare company that she runs i
help her
i help her run it you know but a lot of
times i'm in situations where it's all
black women in me and it gets a little
awkward
like uh a few weeks ago i was in one of
the in this lady
says to me she confronts me she goes are
you of color
and i was like well i'm not really of it
uh i'm around it
a lot about three four times a week i'm
up in it so i don't know
another joke not for down south but you
know
blessed is the kosher deli next door
so my wife has this skin care company my
wife's best
selling product is uh it has a very
unfortunate name
it's called nut milk uh and i i make it
i mean i don't i i
don't you know i manufacture it with
ingredients you dirty bastards
uh manufactured you know shea butter and
everything but the the nut milk but the
nut milk people
i've always thought you should change
the name no nut milk people no the nut
milk
people love the nut milk and it sells
out everywhere across the country so
one day she uh there's a one jar of it
uh in our in our house and she's like
listen i've been saving this there's a
lady
that's coming to buy it uh she's coming
from east new york
her name's marie uh you know she's gonna
be in a subaru outback i don't want to
come by the house because she's a little
crazy i want just
i need you to meet her out on the street
you know and she's gonna try and short
you 75
she's gonna try and give you 40. uh you
know she's a little desperate she's very
ashy
you know whatever so one guy laughs one
guy laughs at that
she you know so i'm like all right so i
got all these instructions so i'm out
there i'm
out there waiting uh for the subaru
outback and then i see one
uh come up so i knock on the one window
like hey i got the nut milk
and the lady in there is like get the
hell away from the car pulls out a
pepper spray right
uh so i'm like ooh you know wrong lady
um
that's not a good opening you knock on
someone's want to say hey i got nut milk
for your face
you know they're gonna you're gonna get
pepper sprayed that's what i'm trying to
tell you
you got to be very selective so after
that i'm like i'm gonna be much more
selective
you know uh so uh what do you call uh so
another subaru outback shows up so i
said marie there was a lady uh
and and i thought it was her because the
hands were oh man i've never seen
dry hands powders dust is coming off she
looked like she was chopping cocaine in
the basement for frank lucas or
something or
you know breach loading a musket or
something you know
and she's like yes it's me and so uh i
i'm like i got the nut milk and i gave
her a nut milk
and i should have got the money first
you know i should have got the money
first i'm a rookie at this stuff so uh
she gives me 45. i'm like oh no she
shorts me i'm like a 75 right so she's
like she's like well that's all i got
and
she's like i need look at me look at my
hands
my hands the dust is coming off i'm like
how i'm trying to think what we can do
uh and and i'd see in the back of a car
she's got these trader joe's bags
so i'm like i you know i love that
homeless that they got over i'm like you
got you have any of that at home and
she's like why does it matter i got like
six of them like give me the hummus
we'll call it even boom so i
i got the hummus she got the nutmeg
everything works out
thanks lady for laughing she likes the
hummus dude that's at trader joe's
hummus it's underrated
so we live on this block in brooklyn and
uh uh
there is a uh there's a hoarder on that
block i don't know if you guys
have been familiar with the hoarders but
there is a old lady that's a hoarder
that also she's one of those ladies that
um everything is blessed
you know you're like hey how you doing
i'm blessed just blessed
blessed are the blessings that punch the
blessings with the blessings on the
blessings you know
like the blessings get stackable there's
more and more blessings which is funny
to me you know
so one day i got her mad at me i didn't
realize i said to her uh she says uh she
goes says would you mind just helping me
would you mind just helping me bring
some things inside and just some other
things outside and i'm just happy that
there's peace i'm like sure
no problem it's not going her house i'm
bringing stuff in i see
the stuff i'm bringing out is stuff that
i threw out years ago it's like you know
encyclopedia britannica collection my
flip-flops what do you do with my
flip-flops you know
yeah and every and there's cat pee
everywhere it's like there's like a
thousand cats yeah
i mean it's cappy every so my hands are
getting all cat-pee-ish i don't know how
to
you know there's pee from the cats on my
hands
and uh and right then i get a text fro
and and
i i can't i'm like i don't want to touch
the phone with the cat pee hand so i
asked the lady
would you just read the text to me and
it's from my wife and it says
the lady reads it loud it's it says that
she needs me to come home now and make
her
a batch of hot nut milk and the lady's
like well what what is hot nut milk and
i'm like
i'm blessed
[Applause]
my wife has a brother older brother you
know
families it can be a little can be a
little funky
you know it's good there's an older
brother that's obsessed with racism
but says the most racist stuff so we had
a we had a party
right and we invited our friends all
shape size and color
everybody came and he kept he kept going
around the party and offending everybody
with these conversations trap one of my
white friends see you white
see white people uh came from the ice
uh that's why they don't feel cold wear
shorts in october
uh read the final call uh he's got one
of my gay friends in the corner see you
gay see the gay
agenda is trying to infiltrate the butt
uh that's what y'all do
you know it's in everything it's
subversive even in the old cartoons
road runner was gay that's why the
coyote chasing them all over the place
road runner made the
disrespectful comment nice hairy balls
that make you healthy but they censor
that [ __ ] that's why all you hear is
beat beat see that's
that's how that works yeah it's got one
of my asian friends in the corner see
your eyes all squinty it's not genetic
it's denial cause you look down see the
little dick oh no
uh we can find a call
so he's offended everybody at this party
everybody's offended right
i'm like you know my brother-in-law you
know whatever
so uh so he's very paranoid he's very
paranoid too right so next day he calls
me he's like look i had a nice time at
dishware made some uh
some friends uh look i'm trying to get
some reefer
if you could arrange a dime bag a nickel
bag something of this like this old
school amount of weed
you know so i gotta go on a weed
question i know there's a little bodega
in the neighborhood that i think is a
front
because there's no merchandise you had a
constant stream of customers you know
there's
like old-ass canagoya beans in the
window box the cornflake still has bruce
jenner with a javelin on it you know
you walk inside there's a picture of
menudo on the wall with the eyes cut out
you know police
okay you know have cockfights in the
back with the chickens not like
i want whatever so i go in there
i buy this thing it comes in a clear uh
plastic
tube it's got a picture of a guy in a
wheelchair on it and it's called the
crippler right i'm like
and i asked the guy i'm like is this
really strong the guy's like just roll
just roll
or i'm like okay roll roll so i call
i call my uh my brother-in-law and uh
i'm like hey i got and he's very
paranoid he's like uh and he hangs up
the phone right so he calls back he's
speaking in code
he's like did you uh did you uh uh get
the contract
i'm like the what the contract did you
get the contract i'm like
the contract yes i got the guy how many
pages was the contract i was like 50
50 pages i told you a five or ten page
contract i'm like a five or ten page
contracts and have seeds and stems in it
god damn it hangs up the phone
fbi is going to move in at any minute
so he calls me back he's like meet me at
the promenade at midnight never been
there to prominence big pier overlooks
the east river so i go out there at
midnight
and i don't even recognize him he's in
disguise he's got a trench coat on he's
got a fedora
he looks like mcgruff taking a bite out
of crime
he's making a fake phone call at the
last phone booth in brooklyn i'm walking
over and something's wrong because he's
like black hawk down vc in the bush
principal in office
cracker on the cheese slip and flop
abort mission mutiny on the bounty
what are you what are you talking about
it's like meet me in a diner in 10
minutes
10 minutes so i wait 10 minutes i go
into the diner it's midnight there's no
one really in there i go sit down at the
booth next to him he puts on his
production of how he doesn't know me
you know coffee for this gentleman i've
never seen before you know
rest your feet where is stranger and
then he slides this napkin over and
something's written on it it says 5-0
at the cash register and i look there's
a 70-year-old security guard buying a
cup of coffee i'm like that guy's not a
cop god damn it he eats the napkin right
he's yelling at me
[ __ ] you ruin the car i'm like i
quit yeah i don't want to work for this
company more take your p.o.t
so i leave right so apparently this
stuff was very strong
you know much stronger than whatever he
was used to cause like two days later
i get this call and it's the code again
he's like
uh it's me uh the flight to jamaica
uh has been circling the airport for the
last 10 hours
when's the plane going land when the
plane go land
i'm like what there was a jalapeno in
the cannoli you understand
[Laughter]
i'm like what the uh the train went
express uh now i'm
in the bronx everybody's speaking
spanish you understand
uh the hot tub water was dirty and now
when i pee it stinks i'm like what are
you talking about it's like
i smoked a contract every page now i
can't feel my legs
[Laughter]
i'm like dude i don't understand he's
like you know what i'll tell you
what it is just because you're jewish
that's what it is
see the jews what they do is they
miscommunicate you miscommunicated the
potency
that's what you do and that's how that's
how circumcision got invented
it was a miscommunication of agriculture
advice from god to moses
god said tell them if they want them to
grow they must chop the tops off the
crops moses said time to time something
and that's what happened that's how
that's how it went down
i'll tell you this people want to know
what comedians think about and you know
like what do we think about
during the day and for me for does not
make any sense
but when i get stressed out i think
about pigeons
i just think about pigeons right i cast
them in different scenarios
you know like you never see i feel like
the pigeon is a disrespected bird
you know every other bird's got a nature
special or something like that
you know you don't ever see you never
see a pigeon nature special
narrated by some guy from brooklyn you
know uh the pigeon is a beautiful bird
note the foliage it's like blue and gray
with dirt
you know so we can blend with the filth
you know
the pigeon uh he's originally from
brooklyn people don't know that but if
you look at him you can see because he's
all built up top and he's got the skinny
little [ __ ] legs like everybody you
know
working out at the gym over here
the pigeon uh he don't eat regular food
he likes cigarette butts chicken wing he
don't care
no mostly carbs
or the pigeon uh the pigeon you know he
don't fly too far
i mean he's [ __ ] fat look at him boom
three feet into the puddle over there
the pigeon has low self-esteem this is
why he's always nodding he's going like
this she can trying to psych himself up
you can fly you fat bastard you could no
anyway that's what goes on in my head
think about pigeons my wife
my wife uh you know deals with real
animals what she does she uh
she fosters animals like she'll bring
these
animals off the street you know and she
don't tell me like i'll get home from
doing shows it's good to know if there's
a pitbull in the bedroom
you know open the door it's all darker
what's that it's bitey fantastic
new addition to the family so uh we we
end up adopting we end up keeping this
one dog
right and i love the dog i start getting
really close to the dog you know
and then the dog develops tongue cancer
i don't know how that happens i guess
that's yeah it's a
maybe years upon years of licking your
own balls i don't know how it happens
right
so we got to take him to the vet their
vet removes part of the tongue now he
barks with
like a lisp you know he's like that like
a mike tyson bark
boxing boxing is a very physical sport
he's his big dog he's got this little
bark all the other dogs what the [ __ ]
going on over here
so consequently because of the operation
his salivary glands have been
compromised he can't
uh digest regular dog food so my wife
cooks for him he gets a steamed broccoli
and chicken and then when she goes away
she cooks for me so it'll be like a
little
tupperware thing for him and a little
one for me well when
what does she she goes away and they got
mixed up and i ate his stuff
you know i'm like this is horrible he
ate mine he's like delicious
delicious
boxing is a very physical sport you know
so but it was it was mexican food that
she had made so about midnight
i'm in the bed chilling and i see the
dog do something i've never seen him do
before he's scooting his ass on the
carpet you ever see that like just back
and forth like a race track you know
just
i'm just watching it you know it's like
wimbledon you know like wow look at that
oh there he goes again
i'm like what's going on then he pulls
up to the bedroom door and he starts
looking he's panting he's like
i'm like you gotta go he's like no so i
let him out of here but he books that
elevator he pushes the button
you know we get downstairs like he
doesn't even make it outside and it's
like it's huge it's like a map of italy
there's a boot you know it's coming
and i got the little bag and i'm trying
to do the math like two trains leave at
midnight how do i clean up this
and some lady from the building's like
you better i'm like lady i need a
forklift and a snow shovel
you know why don't we macgyver a
contractor bag and make a little you
know
you know doggy depends or something but
it was kind of funny to me it was kind
of but when you laugh at that stuff
karmically it comes back to you so i'm
in brooklyn i'm
walking in prospect park one day it's a
beautiful day about 70 degrees kind of a
cool day
and i'm a little hungry and there's a
falafel stand so i'm like ah
yeah i'll just grab it yeah dude's got
all his fingers it'll be fine
you know that's my criteria you know so
he's like
one day he wanted a hot sauce i'm like
put the put the hot sausage like you
wanted a white sauce i'm like put the
wizard
and put the white soap but a white sauce
must have been sitting in the sun
because about a half hour later my
stomach you know
it's it's it's like that that satanic
what is that and then it's like your ass
sends the rest of your body attacks like
you know those plans you have this
afternoon you're going to be
rescheduling that's what's that's what's
going down
i got middle middle eastern music coming
on my ass
it's itching like there's a spider and a
wool turtleneck breakdancing or
something back there i'm like oh i got a
[ __ ]
so i start to run but you can't let the
ass cheek separate you got to keep them
locked together so i'm like hobbling
i'm hobbling along and i'm getting
religious like please please
anything because i'll open a homeless
shelter i'll do whatever you know
please my stomach's like
you know i get to the bathroom it's out
of order i'm like no
you know and everything's reminding me
of it there's a kid on the corner
beatboxing
you know music's coming out there's a
homeless guy talking to himself this
worldly [ __ ]
this world is [ __ ] i'm like quiet
some lady comes up could you take a
picture of me and my daughter i'm like
it's not a good time they didn't take a
picture my stomach's looking
out of your hand
[Laughter]
terrified this poor woman so now i'm
like i'm 52 i don't want to [ __ ] my
pants
what am i gonna do i'm like you know
what it's essentially i'm just gonna hop
in these woods
there's a tree that's fallen that's what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna knock it out you
know nobody's gonna know and it stays in
this room by the way just gotta stay in
this room
cut the cameras off so uh so i'm
squatting there
and uh you know every time about that
you know it's quite i'm like oh this is
horrible and i look over on the other
side of the tree respond there's another
dude squatting
i'm like what are the chances that we
both ate at the same falafel state
so i kind of give them that look of
solidarity that dude looks over me and
smiles i'm like why is he smiling
another head pops up from behind the log
i'm like ow
that's why people hate new york city you
think you're in a park having a family
picnic
three feet away someone's having
explosive diarrhea someone's getting
blown it's like a bermuda triangle
dysfunction
so i'm trying to finish and you know i'm
remembering all boy scout stuff like
three leaves and shiny
uh don't wipe behind me you know
and a bike cop comes up it is the most
embarrassing moment of my life he's like
did you do that
i'm making stuff up like no there was a
giant squirrel with a cup of coffee and
a brand muffin
he went that way if you pedal really
fast you could catch him
he's like i should arrest you i'm going
to give you a tip like arrest me what
are you going to put me on the
handlebars man you know
it's allergy season you better hope i
don't sneeze or it's gonna be officer
down
officer now
that guy looks at me and goes i just got
one question for you he's like what were
you thinking and i was like
that the pigeon is a beautiful bird
so i grew up in a kind of a crazy i grew
up in kind of a crazy house
right you know dad jewish mother german
the unjewishest of the uh
and they were both artists they were
both artists and they used to uh and
they would argue a lot right they'd
argue a lot and
you know my mom would get mad at my dad
she would lock herself in a room play
german marching music you know that was
that was my family it's been like
einstein
my dad's beating on the door like
everything you know
so you know i could you know i really
had no choice but to go into comedy
um the story gets a little darker so
so my mom you know being german
she had uh she had a lot of beefs with
people in the neighborhood there would
be like you know these beefs that
uh and uh you know there was a lady
across the street one of our neighbors
named tina and tina she always you know
she was always
fighting with tina and uh uh
you know it was it was pretty even it
was pretty even at first but then my
mother
got alzheimer's and you know it was very
sad for us and everything she started
losing
and tina would tina would still take
shots at her you know tina and so
i started doing comedy and and
everything and
uh one day my mom's there and she's kind
of like
and tina comes over and she goes to me
she goes uh i wonder what you where you
get i hear you're doing comedy i wonder
where you get your sense of humor from
probably your crazy mother right and i
see my mom like and uh walks off right
she had
because think about alzheimer's you'll
have a little recognition once in a
while you get a little flashback right
so i see my mom
tina was scared of bugs she had a phobia
of bugs
and in dc they had these cicadas that
would leave these shelves
on the trees these like translucent
shells so i see my mom walk over and
grab one of the
grab one of the shelves and go over to
tina she's like tina i got something for
you
right she opens her hand and tina is
terrified but she won't show it
she won't show it she's like karen i'm
not scared of that she's like it's just
a shell
and my mom's right that's right it's
empty like you
and crushed it right and tina had just
had a miscarriage so it added a little
extra yeah that's that's how we roll
that's a
very german very german
scrunch so my mother passes away and
it's very sad for us is about
seven eight years ago seven eight years
ago and uh
you know very sad very sad you know and
uh uh
one thing she one thing that she had was
this hot sauce recipe
that everybody loved this she used to
make it at all the parties and it was
the hottest thing you ever ate
i mean i've never experienced anything
so hot it was like all the scotch bonnet
peppers the
jalapeno everything and she would chop
it up and she never gave anybody the
recipe it was delicious
before she died she left a recipe for me
she wrote it down
and uh you know and so we were having a
memorial at my father's house right
we're having a memorial
and uh we're all very sad and i'm like
you know what i'm gonna make i'm gonna
make
that pepper sauce for everybody so i get
all the peppers i'm chopping it up i'm
looking at the recipe and everything and
this stuff is so hot you know it's like
it's a you know it's coming off and i'm
chopping up the peppers and
finally my dad's like look just take a
break go
you know to the liquor store get some
vodka we're gonna blow this out right so
i'm like alright
so you know i go pee i'm driving to the
liquor store all of a sudden i realize
my dick is on fire and i can't figure
out why it's because i touched it with
the pepper hands
so by the time i get to the liquor store
i got tears coming i got snot you know
i'm crying
you know the korean guy's like oh you
don't look 20 off right
i'm driving home like it keeps getting
worse and worse and worse i'm like i'm
not gonna make it i'm gonna i'm gonna
die i'm gonna crash this car and i'm
like i gotta calm down i gotta think of
what to do
and what and the thing is you know
whenever you been in a bad situation you
got to think about when were you in a
similar situation
and what did you do to get out of it and
i remember once i went to an indian
restaurant and i had this hot sauce
called vindaloo it was the hottest thing
i ever ate right and
it was so hot i hallucinated like i saw
there was one waiter i saw three of them
you know and you know are they okay are
you okay are you okay
right i'm like ah and the guy's like
drinking this mango lassi drink it the
mango
lassi right and he hands me this giant
white drink
i'm like what's that he's like it's a is
it yogurt
is it cool the daddy gonna cool the
inside drink at the mango lassi
right so i'm like manga so i drink it
immediately it cooled the pepper right
immediately it was amazing right so
i'm driving along i'm like manga mango
lassi you know i get home all the people
are milling around i'm like manga lassie
mango lassie i get to the refrigerator
open it there's a giant vat of stony
field yogurt with the strawberry on the
bottom i grab that thing
i go into the bathroom i jam my dick
into this yogurt i am [ __ ] this
yogurt i'm balls to eat the tip is in
the strawberry
i'm like manga mango
and it's so it feels so good it's
probably illegal you know it should be
but it feels so good and and i'm like
and i'm you know it's just
crazy because i'm like i'm crying
because my mother's died
you know i'm like and i'm laughing
because it's so ridiculous
and uh you know i'm [ __ ] this yoga
and i turn around and the bathroom door
did not close properly
and tina is standing there with a child
right
and the kid the kid's looking right at
me and he goes to t and he goes
what is that man doing to that yogurt
and she leans over
and says people grieve in different ways
i'm dc benny everybody i hope you
enjoyed this show
thank you brokerage thank you long
island for having me here
miss you mom good night guys take care
[Music]
[Applause]
you